[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
Hollywood in the Free State of Florida
here for the Patriot Awards a highlight
of the Year good evening and welcome to
Tucker Carlson tonight the collapse of
the cryptocurrency exchange FTX is even
if you're not interested in
cryptocurrency a history changing event
it may turn out to be the biggest single
day loss of Assets in the history of
money billions of dollars evaporated in
just moments and it's still not clear
what happened to a lot of that money it
just disappeared and as it did it
sparked a growing financial crisis
across entire sectors of the economy a
disaster that quite possibly could get
very worse very soon
but the story of the FTX implosion is
bigger even than the global recession it
may cause
it is the story of the complete and
utter Corruption of the people who run
our country
the very people who should have been
covering and regulating and reigning in
FTX and his 30 year old founder Sam
bankman freed were instead profiting
from the scam not just a few of them
nearly all of them from the news media
paid off by Sam bankman freed to the
leadership of the democratic party also
paid off by Sam bankman freed to the
chairman of the Securities and Exchange
Commission the SEC commissioner himself
Gary Gensler they all knew that FTX was
not a real company and that Sam bankman
freed was a fraud and if they didn't
know that they certainly should have
known that because it was very obvious
to anyone who bothered to pay attention
one of the few who did pay attention was
a short seller called Mark cohotis who
took one look at Sam bankman freed SPF
for short and recognized here is a con
artist obviously watch this tape which
aired on hedge eye TV a small investment
advice Channel back in October
when anyone tries to pin SBF down on
where he made his money you can't get a
cogent answer then you take into account
that SBF
is bailing out
known ponzis and frauds in the crypto
space everyone who's gone bankrupt or is
a proven fraud but nothing here fits
everyone everything reads like this
thing is a complete scam and I think
this thing is dirty and rotten to the
Core
so if that guy
on a small audience investment Channel
could tell that Sam bankman freed was a
fraud
where was Gary Gensler of the SEC
and by the way the tell in the sentence
you just heard is that Sam bankman freed
couldn't explain where he got his money
here you are a 30 year old billionaire
how'd you do that
if you can't tell us then maybe that's a
red flag and you would think most
investors would have recognized it but
for the most part they didn't
nor do they seem to notice the obvious
incompetence of Sam bankman Freed's
business partner girlfriend Caroline
Ellison
Ellison was totally and obviously
unqualified for the job she claimed to
have she had no track record of success
at anything she reportedly wrote online
about her drug use
and then on a podcast back in May months
before the collapse
Caroline Ellison just came out and
admitted that she had no idea what she
was doing watch this do you think that
you have been able to pull this thing
off without your mathematics degree or
it has been the pillar of your trading
activity
uh yeah absolutely could pull it off
without my math degree
I use very little math when you start
out as like an intern and you you know
do something and accidentally lose you
know maybe a thousand dollars for your
desk you're like oh God like everyone's
Gonna Hate Me Now like this is terrible
and uh yeah over time you have to uh
sort of yeah get comfortable with larger
and larger uh swings of money
um
yeah trying to think of a good example
of a
trade where I've
lost a ton of money
um well I don't know I probably don't
want to go into specifics too much with
that
no big deal it's not mine and no there's
no math here at the cryptocurrency
exchange let's send her billions of
dollars
lost a lot of money a lot of money that
investors including institutional
investors including individuals who are
hoping to retire with that money all
gone because we don't do math it's so
outdated
but here's the amazing thing none of
this seemed to phase the biggest
institutional investors Sequoia their
entire job is to what assess risk
but it wasn't really about risk and
rewarders but something else earlier
this year Michael Grimes a former
spokesman for Bill Clinton who seemed to
be making an awful lot of money somehow
in the financial World approached Elon
Musk the world's richest man with an
investment offer on behalf of SBS Sam
bakeman freed wants you to invest Elon
Musk didn't get to be the richest man on
the planet by investing in things like
that so he apparently spelled BS and
turned Grimes down but in their exchange
which has since become public Grimes
multiple times told musk that by the way
Sam bankman freed is a huge donor to the
Democratic party quote major Democratic
donor crimes wrote to musk second to
Bloomberg in donations to Biden campaign
what does that have to do with the
investment it should be irrelevant but
that was the substance of the pitch
what is this exactly it doesn't quite
sound like a business it sounds like a
hybrid of some kind and not in a
reassuring way now some of this was
happening in secret but a lot of it was
happening right out in public right in
front of the news media and of course A
lot of them knew Sam bankman freed
because he was sending a lot of the
money and when he wasn't he was
desperate for the publicity they could
provide Sam bankman freed was on the
cover of more magazines than Madonna
so they probably should have been asking
questions about his business but none of
them did they promoted him watch
they call him the JP Morgan of crypto
right
yeah the Michael Jordan of crypto if you
will so why should you care about a
floppy-haired vegan fidget spinning
crypto billionaire who occasionally
sleeps on a beanbag chair during the
so-called crypto winter the 30 year old
CEO has been referred to as crypto's
white knight JP Morgan
of this generation Sam bankman Freed's
FTX is he the Jade Gould of our era or
is he the JP Morgan of our I think it's
yet to be determined yet to be
determined is he Vanderbilt he could be
see Harriman possibly who's the credit
mobile air Scandal see Carnegie
[Applause]
he's a GP Morgan of finance of crypto
he's the Michael Jordan of crypto but
wait a second Michael Jordan's not in
crypto he played basketball well Sam
bankman frees not really in crypto
either
how are we all getting rich who knows
don't ask questions he's a JP Morgan
he'll be a trillionaire
so why were all these people pushing a
scam that any normal person even a
person with no background in finance and
just sort of a Elementary understanding
of profit loss equations could have seen
was probably going to collapse in the
end
now we're not sure stupidity clearly
plays a role so does the herd instinct
so all we can ask really is who is
benefiting from all of this well we know
the Democratic party benefited as we
told you Sam bankmanfreen donated 40
million dollars to Democrats this cycle
that's more than any other donor apart
from Soros then he pledged another
billion dollars for the next election a
billion dollars in one election because
that's democracy
he wasn't doing this in private he was
bragging about it and then he was going
on in public about how politicians
Democratic politicians were begging him
for money watch this
so how do you find political fundraisers
they come to you directly is it easy to
get to you and say we need this money
for this candidate and what type of
candidates you tend to support oh yeah
well if you if I you know pulled out my
phone here and just looked at my last 10
text messages you know about half of
them are going to be uh people asking
for you know politicians asking for for
contributions
so why were you telling us this in
public and by the way if you're shaking
like a naked man in a snowstorm in the
middle of an interview
maybe there's something wrong with you
send that boy another billion dollars
so how substantial are we overstating
this we're making a partisan points that
things collapsed it was clearly a Ponzi
are we trying to attack the Democratic
party now no it's actually Justified
this guy was a major major donor
according to head of Citadel defeating
Donald Trump was literally on the
balance sheet of FTX watch this
FTX
crosses a into a into a zone that all of
us are worried about you know on the
balance sheet of ftx's line called Trump
lose
and Sam was the second biggest donor to
democratic candidates
I'm going to leave it to everybody else
to draw their own conclusions about what
you're saying here
another report says we're out of time we
can't go too deeply into that really
let's go more deeply into it's pretty
interesting so of course politicians
love the guy because he was just a cash
spigot and that's what they want most
but where were the Regulators because
there is a government that's supposed to
be independent of office holders a
regulatory state that keeps ponzis from
happening where were they well Sam
bankman freed was himself invited to
Washington to consult on crypto
regulations
and then he posed for a picture with
Maxine Waters who's the head Financial
regulator in the Congress and then the
Washington posters the hometown
newspaper of government did no reporting
on his actual business they just wrote a
puff piece about how cool is it that the
guy with funky hair can't sit still and
sleeps on a bean bag is getting super
rich
how do we pull this scam how did he do
that
well he did it with religion that's the
quickest way to blind people if they
think you share a common faith
maybe they'll ignore it and that
religion is effective altruism there are
a lot of effective altruists maybe you
haven't heard of that
it's it is a kind of religious movement
it's very popular in the tech world and
the finance World throughout Silicon
Valley and parts of New York the idea is
that you make money not because you're
greedy not because you have a bottomless
pit inside you if need that can never be
filled
but because you want to help other
people and you want to help them in the
most efficient way you want to benefit
the greatest numbers of people in the
most efficient way so that means
effective altruist gets you underpaid
their housekeepers they get to stiff The
Waiter on the tip and of course they
need those to say they do
but that's okay because they're deeply
concerned about abstract tragedies like
global warming so if nothing else
effective altruism gives you a moral
cover as you rip off investors in order
to live tax-free in splendor in some
beachfront Paradise as Sam bankman free
did and to this day continues to do he's
still in Albany in the Bahamas so it
goes without saying the same bank and
free talked a lot about effective
altruism and return FTX enjoyed a very
high ESG score higher than Exxon
which gets your ambulance to the
hospital and you're playing in the air
to see your kids and heats your home
Sam begman freed was considered a moral
leader even as he was ripping off
millions of people
but no one benefited long term from
ftx's collapse or will benefit more than
government Regulators they are pointing
to FDX and demanding more control over
cryptocurrency and ultimately the end of
the cash economy
why do we think they're going to do that
because they're already working on it
SEC commissioner Hester Pierce said this
week the demise of XTS could be a quote
Catalyst for more regulation so why
should you worry about that well because
as we saw in Canada last year
crypto is a huge problem for governments
governments can't control ideally
cryptocurrency you can't freeze
someone's personal cold wallet with
crypto in it if you don't like what they
say so what does this have to do with
the collapse of XT FTX
well it turns out that Sam bankman
Freed's girlfriend Caroline Ellison has
a lot of connections to Regulators in
fact the biggest regulator of all in
this country her father Glenn is an MIT
Professor who worked at that University
alongside drumroll please Gary Gensler
the head of the SEC which is in charge
of cryptocurrency Regulation
ftx's general counsel used to work with
gensor on the Commodities future trading
Commission Now gensor is about to get a
lot more power
so this thing
swells to unsustainable size and
inevitably implodes it collapses and
that collapse is used for pretext to do
what they've been planning to do all
along so probably shouldn't shock you
that right after FTX has collapsed every
major Bank in this country announced a
new partnership with the New York fed to
establish a new digital currency oh
digital currency the one they can
regulate and control Citigroup Wells
Fargo MasterCard HSBC all working on a
12-week digital dollar pilot
the FED describes this project as a
regulated liability Network so what does
this mean long term well
if they have control of your money
because it's digital you can't stash it
under your bed if they don't like what
you say they can turn it off and you're
impoverished
in other words this whole thing is a
bigger scam even that it seems and it
was made possible by political
sloganering and Sam bankman freed if
nothing else is not stupid and he knows
that well as he put it in a message to a
reporter the other day from his hideout
in the Bahamas the woke posturing is the
most effective possible business boy and
we're quoting I feel bad for those who
get effed by it he wrote by this dumb
game we woke westerners play where we
all say the right chibilis and Everyone
likes us
in other words if you suspected all this
was a scam
all the moral posturing all the lectures
you get about how they're great and
you're bad this was all the way to Blind
you to the fact that there was a massive
ripoff going on you might be on the
right track subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube channel to catch our nightly
opens stories that are changing the
world and changing your life from Tucker
Carlson tonight